[Music]
spaces are well distributed
well connected the act campus is very
open and transparent
i pass this spot a dozen of times a day
sometimes i would stop for a moment to
enjoy the view
the atmosphere here is peaceful with
cream pockets of trees
and flowering plants dotted around the
campus
the blocks are oriented in favor of the
prevailing winds
allowing them to be well ventilated and
passively cooled
this is where i work and live
[Music]
my name is carlos bagnon i am an
architect
professor technologist and father
i always imagine living in a limitless
space
where i could create without any
constraints
the opportunity came for me to join
seotd
a new and innovative school driven by
design
and technology
i remember my young professor's passion
in teaching
they opened my eyes to see what
architecture can be
we were educated through a pioneering
curriculum where no project briefs were
given to us
how do we begin the answer eventually
became clear
begin anywhere
i never taught my students how to design
a specific
object or space i prefer to explore
systems
there are possibilities and degrees of
adaptation
with these mindsets the same idea can
then be applied across
any scales and contexts
erlap which stands for architectural
intelligence research lab
is a multidisciplinary space where
architecture intersects
science technology and arts
in airlab we create products systems and
spaces
that aim to increase sustainability
my practice and teaching reinforce each
other flowing naturally together
[Music]
we work with companies like db schenker
helping them with their upcycling
initiatives
to design for a circular economy we need
a shared value in creation together with
the employees
we are assembling an entire space made
out of
scrapped packaging sharing about the
lifecycle of the materials
help us create awareness between the
users the objects
and our environment design
shapes how we experience our world when
designing
i like to learn from the most
fundamental fabrication processes
in order to push their boundaries
places like refined are unique you can
experience first
hand the fragile glass bottle
transformed into a malleable
and soft body with mastery glass can
take shape to wherever your imagination
can bring it no outcome is exactly the
same
every piece is unique and remarkable in
itself
[Music]
similarly design teaching is not a
linear process
it takes lots of practice
experimentation
and getting to work with different
students molding them
bringing out the best in them
once a product of gentrification the
hawker center
is a creation of different cuisines
housed under one roof
low passat is the oldest marketplace
from the colonial period
in the evenings tables and chairs take
over the road
creating one of the most vibrant public
spaces in the city
my students and i had the chance to make
use of technology to preserve the
collective memory of this place
using 3d scanning the volumes textures
and the interactions of people with the
spaces were captured
the data will be available to guide
future generations to imagine
a more productive and sustainable hawker
center
[Music]
starting a new project is like venturing
into the unknown
i tell my students to always bring an
optimistic vision
and a willingness to take risks
i learn a lot by observing my song play
i see his personality developing his
abilities
and preferences children are naturally
creative
in their own ways
i strive to create opportunities to
bring out the best of my child
guiding him every step he takes while
still
giving him plenty of room to experiment
and fail
my first year students are like my
newborns
like how i guide my son i build upon the
strength of each
student helping them develop their own
design
identity
[Music]
gardens by the bay is an inspiration to
me
i resonate with its ethos i believe that
a density
can also be a beautiful garden
what exists expectations is how it
reimagines
structures combines technology and
upholds the values of sustainability
i imagine how wonderful it would be to
contribute my work to this landmark i
respect immensely
that dream came true with hermes a
pavilion
nested amongst green spaces
i set out to create an ethereal
atmosphere for visitors
by highlighting selected vista points
within the garden
the pavilion has to be structurally and
visually light
this is made possible with 3d printing
technology
i see the boundaries in architecture
expanding
technology is changing the discipline as
we know it
the future belongs to those who dare to
dream and have the courage to act on it
will you join me
foreign